we are just over a year away from the
start of the 2020 Summer Olympics it's
gonna be in Tokyo and hundreds of
American athletes are competing for a
chance to go we recently met one of
those athletes who's hoping to make her
Olympic debut in the equestrian show
jumping her name is Jessica Springsteen
and if her name sounds familiar yep she
is Bruce Springsteen's favorite daughter
nici batise an equestrian herself took a
ride with Jessica in Florida recently
and Niki I hear Jessica is very very
good I also hear this sport can be
dangerous good morning Gail Jessica is
an amazing top writer and this is a
sport not for anyone with the fear of
speed and Heights
equestrian show jumping combines both
athleticism and strategy
right now Jessica Springsteen has ranked
5th in the nation while training and
competing year-round so this is your
office this is my office not a bad place
to work every day she may be the
daughter of the boss
Jessica Springsteen everyone but Jessica
Springsteen was born to ride to the
equestrian show jumping involves
galloping horses up to 30 miles per hour
over 13 jumps as high as six feet and as
wide as seven each course is designed
with challenges like tight turns triple
jump combinations water obstacles and a
time limit which is usually under 90
seconds we have our young superstar
Jesse Springsteen a clean round heard
with the fastest time earns the win and
usually means a trophy and tens of
thousands of dollars in prize money you
were ranked fifth in the US right now
you have a really good chance at making
the 2020 Olympic team how hopeful are
you oh I don't know it's gonna be really
tough but one day I think I'll be there
equestrian events and the Olympic Games
are one of the only in which men and
women compete against one another I
think it's great you see a lot of the
top riders are women and men it's so
equal and it's amazing and it's always
such a surprise to people this is my
happy place I think here at rushy Marsh
farm in Wellington
Florida you want a carrot Springsteen
trains on six horses a day to help prep
for year-round competition to win in
this sport a horse and rider need to be
in perfect harmony she is as much a
celebrity in this world as her rock star
parents cheering their daughter on from
the stands in the public's eye how have
you been able to go from Bruce
Springsteen's daughter to jessica
Springsteen champion Rider Olympic
hopeful growing up in New Jersey
everyone was so used to seeing my
parents everywhere and going to school
there especially with riding when I was
so young I didn't even realize what was
going on I think and as I've gotten
older it's so normal now jessica says
her mom Patti ski alphas love for riding
inspired hers and one question everyone
has is how do you make a horse jump I
know you have to be at the right balance
the right side of the fence and the
right distance so that they're able to
clear it and make their best jump but
each horse needs something a little bit
different to make them jump jumping your
way to the top of this sport is as
mental as it is physical you're just
focused on what you're doing with the
horses feeling and you're really just in
sync and kind of in the zone are you
ever scared as I've gotten older you get
more nervous you're more aware of what
can happen to you you know you see your
friends have some bad Falls but you have
to be confident you have to be
comfortable I think so much of this
sport from my years of riding is trust
Trust trust and confidence confidence if
you think you can do it you're probably
gonna do it Springsteen won't know for
sure if she makes the Olympic team that
will head to Tokyo until sometime next
year as for her parents she says it's
relaxing for them to watch her compete
and she says she's lucky to have their
support and passion for her career and
when we are talking this is a tough
sport to complete to explain to people
when you meet a horse it's like dating
you either have a media chemistry or you
don't you've got to work towards it or
it doesn't work out at all I love that
in her world that just that Bruce
Springsteen and Patti Schiavi are
probably known as as Jesse's parents I
that that's a very cool thing indeed
they are I've seen them it shows
watching just like any non there yeah
parents Jeremy on other Chancellor's
look good or chances my chances are
pretty good though ultimately select
five equestrians to go to the 2020
Olympics so she's right there she'd be
one of the youngest ever if she does it
so it's not 2020 maybe 2024 yeah my
money's on her and women men and women
equally they they compute so she said
you just have to have confidence you
have confidence you can do it I don't
know go Jessica look Jessica
not only gets you so far on the horse
Thank You Nicki you do too